how long did it take you to write a song
like yellow ten minutes
seriously yeah that evening in other
words you heard it in your head I didn't
hear my that just came out it came
through I'll tell you exactly how
happened we were in Wales and my
microphone was broken or something I was
waiting to record something else and I
was thinking about Neil Young and I was
starting to doing here young impression
just to try and make everyone in giggle
I love Neil Young so I was like there in
this and I was like and it was very
starry out so I was like I can't do any
young fish [__] but that's how it came
out was trying to do that and I never
told anybody that you started to do it
you start to do your Neil Young and
briault this is pretty good and then
yellow came out yeah with the lyrics
yeah
could you play a little of that the way
you did at that time you free the first
game out of you you have to switch to a
guitar is that cool like hey if you got
willing to do switch they anything you
want I'm happy with that I didn't know
you played guitar tail so I'm just
waiting like soundchecking like this we
had another song called shiver which is
on our first record which is okay and I
was waiting to do that and then I was
found this chord because I like to use
strange tunings on the guitar yes
so that chord may I liked it and then
that chord
so that look at the stars right real
Neil Young II and then the rest just
come out come on play a little in my
voice sorry my bad near young lord do it
in your voice okay you
know the things you do
if they were all you
I came for you
no distinction
and it was called yellow
[Music]
so that's it my turn
oh what a thing too
and it was
[Music]
your skin
to something beautiful
[Music]
you know I get so
beautiful that is a romantic song yeah
were you in love with someone at the
door with that that's not about a
specific girl no girls